i farm with
my parents and my wife jamie and our
four kids
here in spin county diversified
operation with
small grains corn beans and cow calf
cattle and cover crops
[Music]
when we plant cover crops we've always
got a handful of species in there you
know it could be
three to eight we've been no-till since
1986.
it's been a real success for us through
the
decades now especially the past you know
several years with the weather extremes
that we've been through here in south
dakota
just being flexible to planting
different things and not being stuck in
a rut with a two crop rotation
really really helps it's allowed us to
be able to still you know produce crops
on our fields and get in and get planted
and save the moisture when needed but
the cover crops
will utilize the moisture when we've got
too much
you know those drought years of 17 and
18 our trend
for our yields kept going up and in 18
we were
really dry our corn looked like
pineapple i mean it was that dry
i just told brian it's just
heartbreaking this is just going to be
the worst year ever
and then we just got enough rain and it
popped out of it and that's all we
needed
it was best crop we've ever pulled off
this farm
that confirmed to us that what we're
doing works and
we can withstand the weather extremes
i feel pretty confident with what we do
and
how we manage things that it it does
bring our stress level down
quite a bit i'm just more comfortable
with what we're doing because i know
it's
sustainable and it's going to work for
us
the last two or three years have been a
great example
on weather extremes and how well
we can perform in those situations that
really
sets your mind at ease this is exactly
what we need to be doing
because we can sustain and get through
these weather extremes and so my stress
level
is significantly less than it used to be
[Music]
you